los diagramas de pelo son una forma de
representar gráficamente una opción o
una serie de opciones en donde
escribiremos su valor y tiempo de
expiración bien lo que tiene que hacer
es trazar una línea horizontal que
representa el precio pactado y bien yo
aquí tengo dos gráficas la primera de
ellas es más común verla en los libros
de texto y la segunda quizás es más
usada por tres hay gente que se dedica a
la enseñanza de las opciones pero son
similares y esta primera es acerca del
valor presente de la opción y su
expiración y esta segunda va a
representar pérdidas y ganancias en si
lo que se pagó por el contrato
simplemente el valor entonces supongamos
que tenemos una compañía abc de valuada
en 50 dólares y después tenemos un call
con 3 ejercicio de 50 a 10 dólares lo
que nos dice es que el propietario tiene
el derecho más no la obligación de
comprar la compañía a veces a un precio
de 50 dólares hasta su expiración
asumiendo que ésta es una opción
americana
de lo contrario si éste fuese una opción
europea
ejercería al final de la expiración ya
que me refiero a que la opción sea al
final de la expiración es el valor en la
fecha pactada en la expiración entonces
si el precio de ejercicio está por
debajo a los 50 dólares el propietario
no ejercerá no ejercerá la opción si no
tiene ningún valor simplemente la va a
dejar expirar pues no hay razón para
ejercerlas bien si abre el precio de
ejercicio estuviera por arriba de los 50
dólares que éste fuera 51 pues ahora si
ejercemos pues habrá una ganancia de 1
dólar pues compra algo a 50 dólares y
venderlo a 51 y si el precio fuera de 60
dólares en el mercado y tú lo compraste
a 50 por supuesto que ejerces pues
tendrás una ganancia de 10 dólares y
luce más o menos así nuestro diagrama de
pib parece como un palito de hockey o
algo así donde antes de 50 no nos
conviene y después de 50 obtendremos
alguna ganancia
ahora si nos vamos a nuestro modelo de
pérdidas y ganancias lo que tenemos que
hacer es incluir lo que pagamos por el
contrato del call
en esta ocasión antes de 50 dólares
donde ya sabemos que no ejercería mos
para no pagar por algo que en sí es más
barato sin embargo tendremos una pérdida
de 10 dólares por lo que antes de 50
dólares nuestra ganancia es 10 negativo
habremos perdió 10 dólares si 10 dólares
que es el precio de la opción y por no
ejercerla luego si de repente el precio
de ejercicio se eleva sobre 50 ya
sabemos que lo ejerceríamos pero aún
tendríamos una ganancia negativa por el
precio de la opción en el intervalo de
50 a 60 claro que ya obtenemos ganancias
pero tenemos que considerar los días que
pagamos por entrar al contrato entonces
a lo máximo que podemos especular es
quedarnos en ceros
y pum de repente el precio comienza a
subir por encima de los 60 dólares y
comenzamos a hacer dinero entonces estas
dos son formas legítimas de realizar
diagramas de pesos para opciones con
este fue un caso particular y son
simplemente dos formas distintas de
realizarlas